[Musique]
bonjour aurélie n'est là bonjour
monsieur livory et bonjour à tous ceux
qui nous écoutent
alors vous mener la liste du cos
s'engage lors du premier tour vous êtes
arrivé en tête du scrutin
vous avez obtenu 32 points 62 % des
suffrages et vous avez réalisé 1709 voit
comment vous analysé ce premier tour ce
premier tour c'est un premier tour qui
est vraiment satisfaisant et je tiens à
remercier tous ceux qui se sont déplacés
aux urnes dans ce contexte particulier
et les 1709 électeurs qui nous ont fait
confiance au premier tour c'est vraiment
un score qui je dirais est exceptionnel
d'une part parce que c'est notre
première candidature et sa marque
véritablement cette volonté d'un réel
changement est de nouveau souffle pour
la commune et c'est un score qui n'a
jamais été égalé par nos adversaires qui
eux se sont déjà présentés aux élections
en 2014 notamment avec une participation
qui était plus faute donc c'est vraiment
pour nous le signe de cette volonté de
la population qu'on tient à remercier de
sa de sa confiance en espérant qu'elle
l'a confirme au deuxième tour ce
dimanche 28 juin il y alors le taux de
participation au premier tour était de
42% il ya une réserve de voix selon vous
alors bien entendu il y a une réserve de
voix puisque avec le contexte sanitaire
avec le co vie de 19
beaucoup d'électeurs ne se sont pas
forcément déplacées il faut
véritablement faire ce travail auprès
des abstentionnistes tous ceux qui ont
eu peur d'aller aux urnes mais tous ceux
qui sont aussi déçus de la politique et
c'est vraiment ce que notre équipe a à
coeur c'est vraiment redonné cette
confiance en la politique une politique
saine une politique propre
une faut une politique n'ont pas fait de
promesse parce que les promesses
n'engagent que ceux qui y croient mais
une politique vraiment de responsabilité
et d'engagement
c'est vraiment cette relation de
confiance que nous souhaitons instaurer
avec la population comment remobiliser
la population après trois mois de
confinement
après tout ce qu'on a entendu sur le
lakovic 19
comment ça se passe comment vous comment
lequel travaillent sur le terrain vous
faites comment est ce que vous êtes sur
le terrain vu comment ça se passe la
campagne allant sur le terrain ça se
passe très bien et je pense que l'elysée
qu'on dit très bien vous respectez les
gestes barrière comment vous comment
vous faites alors bien sûr on rappelle
un la prudence parce qu'elle est
toujours de mise
mais je dois dire que dès lors que nous
avons été confinés le travail c'est
quand même poursuivi et nous avons
démontré que nous sommes demeurés actifs
et innovants dans tous les champs qui
seront une responsabilité de main qu'il
s'agisse du domaine de l'éducation de la
santé de l'économie du sport de la
culture du social bien évidemment nous
avons été actifs
nous avons organisé pas mal de deux je
dirais d'événements autour de toutes ces
problématiques qui préoccupait la
population organisé des forums notamment
pour parler de la de la rentrée scolaire
organisée du soutien scolaire parce que
pour nous c'était fondamental organiser
des forums des changes avec les chefs
d'entreprises de ducos et les salariés
de ducos qui sont aussi inquiets et qui
sont en attente d'informations de
réponses à leurs questions nous avons
vraiment déployer
je dirais des trésors d'imagination pour
rebondir pendant cette période il est
soutenu par londres immense et le maire
sortant
alors le maire n'a pas fait de
déclaration publique
elle se dit que en bas fait il vous
soutient qu'il fait qu'il fait campagne
pour vous parce qu'il a son fils sur
votre liste
alors le maire a toujours dit c'était le
cas au premier tour qu'il voulait
soutenir la jeunesse
ce que je tiens vraiment à rappeler je
ne dirais pas que tout est noir ou que
tout est blanc mais ce que je veux quand
même rappeler c'est que je n'ai jamais
été élu de la ville de ducos et personne
dans mon équipe n'est élu de la ville de
ducos et nette comptable de la situation
est aujourd'hui je peux quand même
regretter que certains fassent leur
campagne en souhaitant nous imputer les
les
les actions de mauvaise gestion qu'ils
pourraient vouloir réputé à l'équipe
précédente
et c'est encore plus je dirais
contradictoire puisque certains se sont
même ont même fait alliance pour contrer
notre notre candidate accepté le soutien
du maire mais vous ne prenez pas son
héritage
je ne pourra prendre son héritage
évidemment je n'en suis pas comptable
alors être s'est il passé avec joël lui
joseph dauguet alors vous avez raison de
poser cette question et ça va me
permettre de clarifier un peu la
situation
alors il a sectionné alors joël dauguet
et bien sûr la liste de ducos s'engage
il était au premier tour il est aussi
sur le deuxième tour joël dauguet nous a
fait savoir qu'il avait des problèmes de
santé
il m'a écrit il a aussi écrit en mairie
il ya un courrier effectivement qui
circulent et qui fait référence à un
mail qui m'a été adressée où il fait
état de sa situation de santé et je
pense que ça ça doit vraiment se
respecter et je trouve ça inadmissible
que certains utilisent cette situation
pour créer des polémiques là où il n'y
en a pas je crois qu'il faut que la
politique reste sérieuse qu'on arrête de
mélanger les gens qu'on arrête
d'utiliser toute espèce d'argument parce
que je peux vous dire que la campagne
elle est rude et nous sommes la cible
je dirai et je demande vraiment aux
électeurs de rester solide de ne pas se
laisser perturber par tout ce qu'ils
pourront entendre parce que ce n'est pas
ça le sens de la politique ce n'est pas
ce que nous voulons incarner
nous voulons une politique propre une
politique bel bien sûr fait d'opposition
mais de respect mutuel
aurélie n'est là je vous remercie c'est
moi qui vous remercie